hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
be doing a web set review from one of my
Fiverr gigs and it came in through
Keller Coleman so coach Keller he wanted
me to check out his website Keller
Coleman calm so let's go check it out so
see if anything's been done on here so
this is the web site comes up Keller
Coleman speaker author entrepreneur now
Keller's been on my newsletter list for
a while so I know him a little bit more
than just a average person writing into
me the website has been updated so
that's good so we're at Keller Coleman
calm here and it looks like everything
is basically leading up to get on this
list so you get this copy of this book
ebook and how to make money online as a
free gift no cost obligation so it's
great that there's a simple call to
action here it's great that there's some
social media signals below here so 54
people have shared it on Facebook that's
awesome what I probably do here I see
you're on YouTube but I know there's a
lot of videos that you've done i'll
probably put a video on here as well so
explaining why people should sign up for
this so somebody doesn't know who you
are if they heard about you either do a
Google search or they find you throwing
your tweets and they just land on your
homepage you want to try to make a
really good impression because they may
not just quickly sign up and go fill in
their name and information here right
you have to build a bit of a
relationship with them first to convince
them that they want to leave their email
with you and it's going to have a
positive impact on them so that's my
first bit of devices I know you do a lot
of YouTube stuff so create a video and
show your passion about this ebook and
why people should sign up and put it
here as well so they can learn more
about it let's dig in on some of the
inside pages to now so naturally if I
came to this page i see this i probably
wouldn't fill this form in yet because I
don't really know who you are so I click
on the about just to learn a little bit
more about what you're all about so this
is great here we got a YouTube video
awesome we got your twitter feed that's
pretty good your facebook you have a
quick bio here so
which Keller community activist use for
young mens groups 14 18 years old you do
football you have eight children my
granddaughter part of a church and your
famous motto so this is good what I
would do as well though here is put in
some of your business information so i
can your homepage you asked me to fill
out this form for your ebook i don't
really know much about you so i'm
clicking on your about page to learn
about you and why I should sign up for
your ebook and you're saying a lot of
personal information here which is
awesome but what I'm looking for here as
well as to figure out why should I trust
this guy if you're telling me you can
help me make money online why should I
listen to you versus the million other
people who are trying to do the same
thing it's a really hard niche to get
into there's so many people who are
promoting ebooks and how to make money
online so you have to stand out and I
think the video is a good option is a
short one with 32 seconds but something
that talks about your background to
convince people that they should sign up
with you right so what have you done
online or what is your business history
a career that inspires people and that
makes people believe that by signing up
your ebook they will be able to make
money online the other thing I would do
here is also have some kind of call to
action for that ebook again so I went to
your homepage I saw the e-book I didn't
sign up for yet because I'm not sure
you're the guy for me or not I click on
your bio and here and I have to go back
to the homepage to fill out that ebook
and I may not do it so you you probably
want to have a call to action here at
the bottom of all your pages you're
inside pages as well to get people to
sign up for for that ebook you probably
see your your rates your conversion
rates increase a lot if you put it on at
the bottom of your of each page let's go
you had the video here in the Twitter
stream let's click on the speaks page
speaking engagements so great again
another video it's awesome you know what
you can talk about you know you might
want to have a little bit more
information here if you're trying to get
corporate clients to book you you know
talk a little bit more about what each
of these presentations are at so
inspiration and motivation is very
general I'm sure you have awesome
speeches and it's great that there's a
demo here but I try to put a little bit
about the details of what you talked
about in each one so real life
experiences stop provoking ideas doesn't
really help an event organizer create an
itinerary around you know what you're
going to be able to really talk about
right any speaker comes up hopefully I
stop provoking ideas and we'll share the
real life experiences but what is it
that you talk about so well you'd want
to do here if you're trying to get
booked as a as a speaker is say here are
five topics that I could talk about and
these are things that will be included
in all of your topics but what are the
five things so if it's talking to youth
like how to get how to get young men you
know off the streets and changing their
lives in as an entrepreneur as an
example that's one of your topics that's
something you could put in here and come
up with five other topics so you can put
in quick description on each one so then
if somebody comes to your site and is
looking to book a speaker they know if
you are fit or not so I would try to
expand a little bit on that and also
have maybe some testimonials so if
you've done some speaking before have
somebody come on and say you know I book
coach Keller he was awesome he made our
event everybody loved him something like
that really helps show that you know
what you're doing and that people really
value your presentation over everybody
else is just trying to become a speaker
and come to think of it I call I put
that on your home page too when you're
talking about the book how you can make
money online I put something in here
with some information from people who've
gone through your ebook right so people
who have downloaded it and had some
value from it and they've seen some
results have them leave a testimonial
hopefully could put their picture on
there maybe even link to their website
if they if they're open to it but
putting some testimonials and he
again will reduce the risk and increase
the likelihood that somebody's going to
want to sign up for that ebook i'm
guessing us to your number one call the
action you want people to do is fill out
that heavy book page so hope that helps
a quick review again we're looking at
Keller Coleman calm for those of you who
are watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes you want to do more of these
videos for you guys and if you have a
thought or question about Keller Coleman
calm or if you want me to review your
website as well feel free to leave it in
the comments below and I will always
check it out and you can always of
course order view through the fiber
website as well where our reviewer
website and I've promoted as well so
thank you for joining me and we'll see
you on the next episode
you